hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and the time has come for
dekku's final quirk to be revealed as
the war arc accelerates to unprecedented
levels dobby is about to uncover his
full backstory before he tries to murder
shoto toga is preparing to use sad man's
parade burning is looking hot so let's
get into it you guys know what to do if
you enjoy our videos and you want to
encourage us to keep it going just leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and if you're new to
the channel or you watch our videos but
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet remember that subscribing and
hitting that bell is a direct way of
supporting this channel and it's
completely free you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the latest chapter starts
off with deku actually flying across the
ocean and trying to make it back to the
mainland on his own in my previous
review i was wondering if maybe he was
moving so fast that he was actually
walking on water but no it turns out
that he's using a combination of
multiple quirks to essentially fly over
the ocean he is mixing float and fajin
and air force to fly across the ocean
but even with those powers deku is
worried that he is still too slow we
can't forget that he has literally
hundreds of kilometers to cover and with
no objects to grab onto because he's on
the ocean black whip can't help him move
faster by slinging off of them this
means that deku can't really increase
his speed any more than this unless he
takes some more drastic measures
and so deku starts thinking about maybe
using the full 100 to make it back to
the mainland faster but that is when the
second user appears and tells deku to
calm down deku is clearly losing his
cool and he's allowing his decisions to
become muddled because he is so
desperate to get back to ua and help his
friends against shigaraki the second
user warns deku that using the full 100
now would run his equipment into the
ground before he even reaches the
battlefield and so instead of meeting
shigaraki at full power he will already
be weaker and exhausted the second user
then asks dekku if he tried to activate
his quirk the final quirk in one for all
and deco admits that yes he had
but the second user warns him against
doing that and he says that his quirk
has to be a last resort after melding
with one for all his quirk has become
much stronger than it used to be back
when he was its user and this creates a
problem apparently the second user's
quirk has transformed into a very useful
but very specific type of power it is
way beyond what it used to be and in
fact it is now well beyond their ability
to control it all of this is giving me
some serious quirk singularity vibes and
it is clear that deku's final quirk is
not only strong but dangerously strong
even the original user of this quirk is
warning deku that it has to be used as a
last resort because there is a very real
possibility that the quirk has already
become uncontrollable and this means
that using it could have serious
unintended consequences the second user
tells deku not to panic and not to try
to use the quirk now he has to believe
in his friends and he has to have faith
that they will be able to keep shigaraki
under control until he arrives and
honestly this exchange was so
interesting i mean we all know that
deku's final quirk will be strong but
what can this quirk be that it is so
dangerous and uncontrollable we don't
know what this quirk is but we do know
that it must be something that would be
useful to deku in this specific
situation that he is currently in that
means that whatever the final quirk may
be it has the ability to somehow speed
up deku's arrival time although it seems
that the potential cost of using it
seems to outweigh the benefits at least
for now stick around until the end of
the video because i will be talking
about what i think this final quirk
could be but for now let's talk about
the rest of the chapter the action then
shifts back to octo island where ochoko
and tsuyu are still facing off against
himiko toga toga proclaims that she is
done with all of them and she vows to
carve out her own path
she then touches her pouch the one
holding the blood vials and she thinks
of twice the implication is clearly that
toga is thinking about using twice's
blood to initiate sad man's parade
although it would be kind of silly of
her to do that on octo island now that
deku has left even if toga
single-handedly takes out all the heroes
on the island that won't have much of an
effect on the battle i mean no offense
to gang orca and all the other heroes
here but they're not exactly top billing
if you know what i mean as toga and
ochako prepare to clash both of them
determined to fight for their true
desires the chapter shifts locations yet
again and this time we're in kamino this
is the place where dobby and shoto were
transported to along with eida endeavor
sidekicks and a bunch of creepy
overpowered nomu everyone is surrounded
by a sea of flames as dabi just fries
everyone and everything in sight it is
implied that his flames have already
thinned out the hero's numbers meaning
that he has already killed a bunch of
heroes with his flames many of the
remaining heroes including eda are
struggling to deal with the insane heat
that is being generated by dobby's
flames they are forced to stay back so
as not to get sucked up into the inferno
and so shoto along with three of
endeavour's sidekicks seem to be the
only opponents that can resist dobby's
flames for long enough to confront him
in battle and one of these sidekicks is
the smoking hot waifu burning so
horikoshi i'm watching you my dude you
promised us no more waifu casualties
okay be cool anyway the sidekicks are
going to be supporting shoto because he
wants to take the lead in taking dobby
aka toya down shoto believes that it is
his duty to stop his brother and due to
the nature of his quirk shoto is
perfectly positioned to resist and
counter dobby's flames and shoto says as
much to dobby he tells him that
endeavour didn't order him to be here
and neither did anyone else he insisted
on being the one to stop his brother now
dabi believes that this only proves that
shoto has become nothing more than
endeavour's puppet but shoto doesn't
care what dobby thinks as long as he can
help endeavour take his mind off of dabi
so he can focus on being a hero in this
difficult time shoto is satisfied all of
this is intensely personal for dobby he
relishes the opportunity to fight his
younger brother endeavour's so-called
ideal specimen and the three sidekicks
that endeavor himself had personally
trained in the past dobby has already
vowed to kill shoto before he takes out
endeavour just so endeavour would have
to live with the knowledge that his
perfect son is dead and he is to blame
so this showdown between dabi and shoto
was always going to happen in fact we
know that this is deeply personal to
dobby because in order to keep up his
flame attacks he is actively burning his
body worse than ever before the skin on
his face and pretty much everywhere else
is burning off rapidly but dobby simply
doesn't care he is smiling from ear to
ear as he embraces this new war the
final war between the heroes and the
villains those who want to save the
world and those who want to destroy it
the chapter ends as shoto asks dobby why
he took so long to reveal himself after
he initially disappeared and was
presumed dead
why didn't he ever come home after he
was injured in that fire where was he
all this time as the skin melts off his
face dabi agrees to finally reveal his
full backstory to his brother shoto he
promises to tell his little brother why
his flames were never extinguished and
how they were able to surpass even those
of endeavour's masterpiece and that is
the final panel the text on the final
page promises that we are about to learn
the rest of toya's twisted backstory
possibly in the very next chapter this
is something that i have been talking
about ever since dabi first revealed
himself as toyah back in jakku we still
only know a small part of his backstory
we know about his childhood as toyah and
we know that he was caught up in a
horrible fire and that he was presumed
to be dead because fragments of his
jawbone were found at the scene but we
don't know anything about him for a
period of over a decade he eventually
shows up as the villain dobby but what
happened in the meantime how did he
survive that fire when he was clearly
severely injured did someone step in to
rescue him
if so why didn't they report that they
found a kid who was badly injured why
didn't they take him to the hospital was
dobby rescued by a villain maybe even
all for one himself
also what was he up to for all those
years between his accident and his first
public appearance as dabi was he just
using that like 10 years to get stronger
or was he up to something that we don't
even know about yet maybe something that
he is about to reveal to shoto i've
always been curious about this part
because a severely injured kid didn't
just survive on his own for over a
decade there must be something more
going on here and i can't wait to learn
the full
dark truth
definitely let me know down in the
comments what you think happened to toya
in the time between his accident and his
first appearance as dabi was he saved by
the villains was something else going on
here will we finally learn something
about deku's dad in relation to dobby's
secret backstory let me know down below
finally let's get back to deku's final
quirk because this is really big and
really important so the only clue that
we have about this quirk is the fact
that the second user was apparently able
to blast through a thick steel vault in
order to rescue the first one for all
user from captivity we also know that
the second user used some sort of
gauntlet on his left arm so all of this
suggests that his quirk should be some
sort of offensive blasting ability and i
mean yeah a powerful blast would likely
be able to propel deku forward faster so
it would make sense for him to consider
using this quirk in the moment that he
is currently in in the story
but if this was just some simple
blasting quirk then why all that talk
about it being a last resort and
potentially incredibly dangerous and
uncontrollable we've seen plenty of
blasting type abilities before and that
just doesn't strike me as some sort of
world shaking ability with extremely
dangerous repercussions i might be wrong
like it might be some type of blast that
could just keep going through things
until it hits an unintended target or
something so it's like you can't control
it once you unleash it it just keeps
going
but again if we look at the vault door
that the second user had opened it
wasn't really destroyed in any way it
didn't even really have a hole in it if
i had to guess what his quirk could be i
would say some sort of time manipulation
ability if deku could potentially slow
down time for others or speed it up for
himself he could certainly get to the
mainland faster and of course whenever
you're dealing with time-based powers
there is always a lot of potential for
something to go horribly wrong but if
this were the case then how would time
powers relate to that vault door which
is our only real clue about the true
nature of the second user's quirk well
perhaps the second user has the ability
to speed up the time for certain things
such as a door so perhaps he was able to
speed up the door's aging process to the
point that it was weakened and he was
then able to blast it open using his
gauntlet in this scenario the gauntlet
would just be a cool accessory that he
uses in conjunction with his time powers
just an additional weapon and not part
of his quirk now i know that this is a
stretch especially if we're talking
about aging a steel door to the point
that it would become weaker like yes
it's possible but that would not be an
easy task it would take a very long time
but hey time-based powers would be super
cool to see especially in the final
battle between deku and shigaraki
personally i don't really know what
other dangerous power the second user
might have so this is my personal guess
if i had to make a guess right now
please feel free to share your guesses
down in the comments what is the second
user's quirk and why is it so dangerous
i look forward to reading all of your
creative ideas down below if you guys
enjoyed this pocono hero video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps me out and
remember that subscribing and hitting
that bell is a completely free but very
important way of directly supporting the
channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord to ego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma in grata algital pate heffa
the red-haired fox hinokami and water
the toasted qi corey mcgowan spidey left
tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews alicia octor bonnie parks
joy and garcia fat boy games kaido might
be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
and alivania if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you